The chaos is hiding in what's irrelevant
and so,
and that's very interesting observation
because since the chaos is virtually
infinite,
it's a real question is where the hell
do you put it while you put it in what
you ignore and you can ignore it as long
as it isn't actively interfering with
your movement forward,
you can assume that it's that it doesn't
matter that it doesn't matter that it
doesn't matter.
Same thing.
All right?
So here's the kicker.
There's one more class of things that
you can run into along the way and this
is where the chaos breaks through.
So let's say
you're moving from point a to point b
and something that you don't expect
occurs and it gets in the way.
So let's say that you're living with
someone and maybe you kind of liked
them.
You're not married so you don't like
them that much because otherwise you'd
ask them to marry you.
But anyways,
um,
and so ha,
quarter of youth as looking for
something better and three quarters view
is half satisfied,
something like that.
And then a person because we're
ambivalent about such things.
And then the person you discover or the
person announces that they've been
having an affair.
Okay.
So then how are you supposed to respond
emotionally to that?
Well,
the part of you that wasn't all that
committed to the relationship is kind of
exhilarated by that.
And then the three quarters of you
that's half satisfied is hurt and,
and you're going to exploit that part
for sure in the ensuing discussions and
not mention the,
oh,
that's kind of exciting that you've
betrayed me that way.
So,
so,
but the point is,
is that you,
that's a whole.
Now what's happened is a whole has you
have this structure that you're walking
on ice thin ice that you're skating on
and now there's a hole in it and the
whole,
we don't even know how deep the hole is,
but you know there's a hole there and so
now you're anxious about it.
They'll maybe also a little bit excited
because God only knows what's down there
but,
but you don't know what to do with that
whole because it could spread very badly
on you.
It could be that you know the whole
relationship was a facade and that all
your relationships have been facades,
facades,
and that the reason that is is because
you're so damn shallow that it's
impossible for you to have a
relationship that isn't just a facade
and that's partly because you don't pay
any attention to other people and it's
also partly because you're malevolent
and selfish,
so that's a nasty thing to discover or
maybe that's the sort of person that
you're attracting,
which would make sense actually,
if that's the sort of person that you
are and so,
so there are certain things that you can
encounter that basically unglue you,
and what happens is that those moments
of being unglued travel up that entire
hierarchy of presuppositions.
It's like because the one of the logical
conclusions to being betrayed in a
relationship is that you are,
that you're truly a bad person.
Now another equally logical conclusion
is that the person that you're with is
really a bad person,
and another logical conclusion is all
people are truly bad people.
You know,
I mean in,
in,
in macro ways,
at,
in microwaves.
You can't trust anyone.
You can't trust women.
You can't trust men.
You can't trust human beings.
You can't trust yourself.
The whole place is a catastrophe.
It's a nightmare.
Well,
then you can fall through into chaos.
Now the way your body responds to that
or maybe you know you're supposed to be
getting a promotion at work,
that's good.
You're all chipper about the promotion
at work and you walk into your boss's
office because he or she wants to see
you and they say,
well,
you know,
we've reviewed your performance over the
last few years and your performance has
been somewhere between mediocre and
decent and we're downsizing and see you
later.
That's not a raise or a promotion,
that's for sure.
That's a whole that you fall into and
the question is,
well,
what do you make of that?
Right?
How do you frame that?
How do you take that emergent chaos and
make habitable order out of?
You don't know.
Is the whole capitalist system rotten to
the core?
I mean,
that's a convenient explanation under
those circumstances.
That's for sure.
Where you're working for a psychopathic
son of a bitch.
Did you make the wrong choice in
university and was that your father's
fault because you never did what you
wanted or was it your fault for not
standing up to them or is it a dying
industry or is maybe there's a wake up
call that you should go do something
else that you've been waiting to do you
know that you've actually wanted to do
your whole life and that's why you're
doing such a miserable job at your
current occupation because you're bitter
and resentful about the fact that you
never did what you want.
You don't know.
It's all of those things at once and
that's very stressful because all of
those things at once is too many things
and that's the reemergence of chaos.
That's the flood.
That's the return to the beginning of
the cosmos.
That's another way that it's been
represented.
Mythologically.
It's the you voyage all the way back to
the beginning of the cosmos when there's
nothing but undifferentiated chaos and
that's what you're confronting and maybe
it's too much for you and often it is.
I mean that that can really.
That can be traumatizing and it can hurt
your brain,
you know it's just too much for you to
bear,
but it doesn't matter.
You're stuck with it,
and so how do you respond to that?
Well,
some of it is catastrophic negative
emotion.
You freeze and that's protective and
maybe you don't even want to move.
You don't want to bloody well get out of
bed for a week and that's because your
body is reacting as if the bedroom floor
is covered with snakes and the best
thing for you to do is just not move.
Just freeze.
Not a pleasant situation to be in
because it's your hyperaroused very,
very physiologically demanding and
there's zero about it that's productive
except maybe the snakes won't see you,
but they've already seen you,
so that isn't helping very well.
So you've got all this undifferentiated
native,
negative emotion,
fear,
hurt,
anger,
guilt,
shame,
emotional pain,
the whole plethora of catastrophes.
And then maybe on the other side lurking
down there is,
thank God I'm done with that job.
I just bloody well hated.
I dragged myself off to work every day
and there's a little part of my soul
that so goddamn happy.
I finally got fired that I can hardly
stand it.
You know,
and maybe you don't even admit that to
yourself because,
well,
that would mean that all that time you
spent at the job was just sunk costs.
You're diluting yourself the whole time.
Um,
it is an interesting thing to consider
those sometimes if you're in the
unpleasant circumstance of having to
fire someone,
you know,
sometimes firing someone is the best
thing that can happen to them,
which doesn't mean that you should go
out and like enjoy it.
Although I have met very disagreeable
people who actually enjoyed firing
people.
And I'll tell you a story about that at
some point because it's quite
interesting,
but you know,
sometimes if someone's just limping
along in their job and doing it as
miserably in wretchedly as they possibly
can imagine,
the best thing you can do to them for
them is to say,
you know,
you're failing at this.
And,
and that doesn't necessarily mean that
you would have to be failing at
absolutely everything else in the entire
world.
So maybe you should just accept the dam
failure and go off and try something
new.
And I mean,
that's terrifying for people and I know
they hate it and all that,
but,
but sometimes it's better than the
alternative,
which is just slow,
torturous death.